première découverte le contrat de
travail il est de 15 heures par semaine
est carrément illégales la durée
minimale de travail du salarié à temps
partiel est fixé à 24 heures par semaine
l'assistante administrative à la
solution il suffit de faire croire que
c'est rebecca qui demande un si petit
contrat et que l'employeur lui accorde
gentiment une dérogation
contrat même si rebecca s'apprête à ne
travailler que 15 heures par semaine
elle doit être la disposition du
franchisé macbook 60 heures par semaine
pour 500 euros par mois
alors florian signifie qu'on aimait
beaucoup le savent et fondateur de
l'agencé a friend comme spécialiste en
communication de crise nous a rejoints
merci flou d'être avec la percée avec
nos collègues - florian vous le savez
c'est mon petit l'outil préféré
est flou hier qu'est ce t'as pensé du
truc sur mac do toi donc c'était autre
chose mon gêné d'abord c'est un
documentaire qui est anglais sur mac do
c'est dommage parce qu'on s'en prend à
une seule marque on aurait pu étudier un
secteur on aurait pu regarder aussi ce
qui se passe chez les concurrents de
mcdo moi j'aime pas l'idée de
stigmatiser un acteur et pas un secteur
même s'il ya évidemment des choses à
dire sur ce secteur d'ailleurs je n'aime
pas non plus l'idée que des fossés
information a été diffusée par ailleurs
on prétendait hier expliqué aux parents
que il y avait des recommandations de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité
alimentaire sur le taux de fer par
exemple de ce que l'on donne à consommer
aux enfants et bien le taux qui a été
donnée hier n'est pas celui de lens s7
un taux erronée et ça je trouve que
c'est l'illustration du business des
documentaires low cost d'élise lucet et
de la société première ligne qui ne
cherchent plus à faire de l'information
et qui du coup enchaîne les poncifs le
soda c'est trop sucré le fromage sur le
steak c'est trop gras ou la restauration
c'est trop dur on ne découvre rien avec
ce reportage et c'est d'autant plus
gênant que élise lucet avait
personnellement incarner un plan média
la veille de ce reportage et elles
s'étaient comportés d'abord non pas
comme journaliste mais comme donneuse
leçon en expliquant qu être une bonne
mère c'était ne pas amener ses enfants à
disneyland et pas chez mcdo bien moi je
trouve qu'elle va trop loin et qu'elle
dépasse au fond le rôle qui est le sien
à savoir faire partager aux français une
information
moi je vous dirai arrêtez ce qui me
dérange à chaque fois sur sa voix je
trouve que c'est très bien ce qu'elle
fait et on sait pas très bien non mais
c'est à dire qu'elle fait son travail
elle a trouvé un créneau horaire mais
derrière elle mais
dernier d'emploi en danger face à chaque
fois non mais à chaque fois elle
s'attaque à des sociétés pour dénoncer
des choses mais il ya plein de gens qui
travaillent dans ces sociétés est au
bout du bout je vous le dis ceux qui
vont être les plus touchés quand les
entreprises le mas fermé à l'emploi sont
les employés qui travaillent là-bas
depuis des années et des années qui
compte sur ça pour faire vivre leur
famille et moi j'ai toujours un problème
avec les gens qui peuvent mettre
énormément de gens au chômage qui
s'attaque en voilà qui sous prétexte de
s'attaquer aux puissants on sait que ce
sont pas les puissants qui vont qui vont
se faire et qui vont être les plus
touchés mais mine de rien les plus
démunis et ceux qui ont besoin de ce
travail pour pouvoir faire vivre leur
famille et ça c'est un problème on l'a
qui me dérange oui alors je suis pas
d'accord avec vous mais avec florian par
exemple parce que vous dites ça embauche
plein de gens notamment des jeunes mais
dans quelles conditions c'est ray
lalonde et des faux contrats de travail
qui sont passés devrait l'annoncer en
caméra cachée c'est à dire qu'on leur
fait signer des contrats de 15 heures on
n'a pas le droit et on leur on leur fait
mentir par courrier donc y'a un gros
turnover parce que les gens ne restent
pas cyril donc vous dites ça créé des
emplois mais ça crée des emplois pas
d'écouter moi quand j'étais jeune je
disais toujours je valais aller bosser
au mcdo chez elle voilà j'aurai une
bonne tout le monde a envie d'aller
bosser au magnoac à un moment il aimait
vous gilles verdez en fait ça je vous le
dis vous êtes encore dans votre rôle qui
deux censeurs et vous ne vous rendez pas
compte de ce qui ce que ça va engendrer
derrière vous rendez compte si demain si
demain la mac do et tous les mac dont un
ferme en france est ce que vous vous
rendez compte du nombre de gens qui vont
être au chômage et du nombre de gens qui
vont galérer d'erilia mistral non mais
non mais vous vous rendez compte un peu
en fait vous pensez qu'à vous enfin non
ainsi honte à vous et fermeront pas ils
feront peut-être moins de bénéfices en
faisant signer des contrats de travail
illégaux cyril on espère aussi j'ai
également les étudiants eux-mêmes certes
c'est illégal les contrats sont illégaux
mais les étudiants eux mêmes ils ont des
heures d'études colossal ils ne peuvent
pas travailler plus de quinze heures par
semaine dans le mac do donc ça les
arrange aussi d'enregistrement de 15
heures par semaine alors certes ces
illégaux est légal mais oui le cheval
paix sociale mais ça leur fait les
étudiants sur les armes ça les arrange
ça aussi c'est que vous n'avez jamais
travaillé de rayman est aussi il a fait
quoi comme travail vous moi j'ai fait
beaucoup de monsieur occuper des enfants
de centres de loisirs et en vrai en vrai
travail mais
j'ai fait des année de sang et de
loisirs l'effet de rigoler j'ai fait des
centres de loisirs à villiers sur orge
dans l'ère des années l'effet coin après
bas après j'étais journaliste mais j'ai
fait des centres de loisirs j'ai ramassé
les pommes de terre j'ai fait des
branches on va les retourner au
boulot merci biko aller oui alors
franchement il ya ce soit le plus
mauvais numéro de cash investigations
effectivement ils ont enfoncé des portes
ouvertes toutes les missions savamment
spar ils font la pub pour les enfants
jusqu'à 40 ans qu'ils ont un clown en
emblème le hamburger c'est pas bon pour
la santé sans blague mais pas besoin
d'eux pour le savoir mais j'ai jamais vu
un truc aussi mauvais qu'ils hier et en
plus ces machines ils ont fait une
séquence sur une prise de sang qu'ils
ont fait une employée alors là ils ont
pompé carrément ils ont plus pomper un
film qui s'appelle super size me qui est
édifié sur les filles qui t'a vrai
j'adore honnêtement hier c'était mais
leurs époux ont tapé cantons contre aj
je suis désolé ce que moi j'ai bossé
quand j'étais à tolbiac au mcdo de la
porte d'italie alors pas très longs
tours secs c'est très dur mais j'étais
bien content de gagner le peu d'eau dès
que j'ai reçu c'est mal d'autres choses
mais on voulait vous montrer cette
petite expérience réalisée par les
équipes de cash investigations avec des
enfances et imax le doigt du reportage
nous avons tout acheter chez mcdonald's
la moitié des menus restent dans la
boîte d'origine et nous avons emballé
l'autre moitié dans des paquets 9 les
enfants sont donc en train de manger
sans le savoir deux fois la même chose
laquelle tu as préféré
quel est le menu que tu as préféré
super une boîte rouge ça
c'est normal ça sahara ils connaissent
la main
je montre un autre extrait qui montre
que disait un peu benjamin castaldi
c'est le jouet sur le jouet du happy
meal
énorme découverte au coeur de cette
stratégie publicitaire existe une arme
de séduction massive le jouer dans le
happy meal si vous pouvez attirer un
enfant à 4 5 ou 6 ans chez mcdonald's il
va probablement continuer à venir quand
il sera adolescents que puis adulte et
puis viendra avec ses enfants
donc si vous avez un dollar à dépenser
dans le marketing dépenser le sur les
anciennes seront inclus
[Rires]
[Musique]
je mets
m
mais
[Musique]
voilà et gilles verdez est content ça
fait super n'importe quoi c'est pas la
peine d'aller au texas interviewé un
spécialiste ville pour les banalités
pareil moi je ne comprends pas que le
service public tolère sur une émission à
charge et malhonnête concrètement
comment ça se passe ils se mettent en
conférence de rédaction ils m'ont alors
qu' on va défoncer aujourd'hui ça mc do
voir autant alors que à charge et c'est
très facile journalistique mans vous
faites des séquences à charles vous dit
que les contrats sont pas en règle etc
c'est faux et pour moi c'est intolérable
c'est indigne du service public voilà
c'est une honte c'est derrière crise
n'est pas d'accord si pour compléter ce
que alors pour compléter ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure vous parler des
emplois qui peuvent être supprimés mais
il ya aussi toutes les familles qui
n'ont pas les moyens tout le monde a
envie de manger bio tout le monde a
envie de donner le meilleur à ses
enfants mais tout le monde moi je suis
contre la malbouffe contre l'élevage
intensif etc mais il ya des réalités
aujourd'hui surtout là qui vont arriver
avec l'inflation etc tous les gens qui
n'ont pas les moyens de manger de la
viande tout le temps et c'est parfois
ils vont au mcdo pour donner à manger à
leurs enfants des nuggets quelque chose
de protéines et française
ça c'est trop facile moi aussi je vais
chez mcdo c'est pas le problème le
problème c'est que les gens qui nous
sert chez mcdo sont exploités sous
utilisé et firent et et c'est ce que
montre le reportage
enquête aux états unis en france partout
c'est du vrai bon boulot arrêté
guillaume fait ça dans un reportage dans
leur part été arrêté d'attaquer les
autres fait ça aussi vous si l'on n'a
pas vu ce que vous avez fait on va voir
tient la combler parce que pour ces deux
ceux qui parlent la compil des
témoignages des conditions de travail
voilà un débat mais chez moi je vais
vous dire un truc demain il vient de
faire un reportage ici ils viennent
interroger des gens et ils viennent
interroger des chroniqueurs ils ont
parti d'aller voir ils vont toujours à
un
truc que c'est comme dans le téléphone
de ta meuf quand tu cherches tu trouves
non mais sans déconner avec deux lits tu
veux prendre le téléphone de ta meuf tu
es sûre et battue va toujours trouver un
truc non mais je te le dis toi ce point
le téléphone de patauger même pas besoin
de le prendre
[Rires]
des conditions de travail peu reluisante
désormais les toilettes sont fermées à
clé et il faut demander l'autorisation
aux managers pour y aller est il normal
que l'une de mes managers m'envoie
régulièrement dans le vestiaire pour me
punir mais je me suis servi un verre
d'eau mon manager me la retirer des
mains et l'a brutalement vider dans
l'évier nous n'avons pas le droit de
boire sans son autorisation
nous n'avons pas de prime pas de 13e
mois pas de ces oeufs pas droit à la
parole pas de syndicat ces témoignages
viennent de restaurants différents
en train de parler gentiment chose
effectivement ça pourquoi pas on dénonce
des conditions de travail et c'est
toujours bien de pointer du doigt quand
les concurrents yade qui me
dysfonctionnements mais en revanche on
ne connaît pas les rites tu trouveras
toujours un témoignage d'un mec qui
situe bien dans les couloirs et avec les
rebelles il ya cyril payet j'ai mangé
une pomme il m'a dit prends tu manges
pas une fois ouvert sur le marketing
toutes les entreprises vont du marketing
pour attirer des clients y compris des
clients les plus jeunes et enfin
dernière chose ce qui est gênant aussi
c'est le j'allais dire le tourbus café
elise lucet pour promouvoir le reportage
et la donne son opinion et là nous dit
c'est bien c'est pas bien mcdo c'est pas
bien parce que les us et décide que mcdo
c'est pas bien lorsqu'elle décide que l
son enfant elle ne le donne mettra
jamais chez mcdo est là en revanche
c'est là que le bât blesse parce qu'elle
n'a pas à nous dire soulès confesse le
fameux les siens tous les moyens et le
bât blesse on prend ça le bas le bât
blesse et souvent batwa new york et
surtout gilles pardon mais ça montre
quoi ça dénonce quoi ça prouve quoi
c'est un pétard mouillé en fait ça fera
rien toi qui est le prix nobel de
l'économie comment veux tu qu'ils
fassent concrètement ces soixante quinze
mille emplois c'est 40 % de jeunes
d'étudiants qui sont contents de pouvoir
bosser parce que ça paye les études
s'appelle une partie du logement social
écrit c'est la crise sanitaire était
bien dans la galère justement à cause de
ça donc qu'est ce que tu proposes
concrètement alors on trippe les
salaires comme ça parce que gilles
verdez dit il faut tripler comme ça ils
auront ils ont rempli mal au dos et
qu'est ce que tu proposes la légalité
des contrats bord alors je vous dis la
vérité serait qu ils ont voulu ferme à
l'agglo y a pas chez une personne va
dire je vais
au contraire même
vraiment pitt alors vous lui en fait été
faites vous vous êtes toujours à côté de
la plaque
il faut prendre faut prendre ça comme
quelque chose d'un format tiff tout
simplement les gens ne vont pas changer
leurs habitudes pour autant moi je
trouve que ellis bus est ce le fait
c'est très très intéressant alors oui
c'est un peu à charge et en même temps
mcdonald's c'est juste le roi du fast
food alors on peut aussi un peu le
piquet de temps en temps donc je trouve
à titre informatif ça très intéressant
mais aussi point b j'ai la dalle en
mai mais honnêtement tu as vu un une
enquête intéressante dans cette émission
m'a tout ce qu'elle fait sur des portes
ouvertes du matin au soir c'est trop
d'émissions sur la banque il faut une
émission sur la vente des produits à
l'étranger ils disent que j'ai de tout
chez dassault il vendre hors taxes des
avions basés à l'étranger nommé vous
rendez même pas compte de ce qu'il
distille dans cette émission pour faire
pour faire du bruit ils sont
complètement mais excusez moi c'est même
score mais le syndic site un mec
calculer un
terme à la flore de tout c'est que tout
ce qui se dit là il commence quand tu
entends gilles verdez qui est quand même
voilà quel sens le sérieux qu est ce que
vous avez envie de lui dire j'ai envie
de lui dire qu'il est douce elle a
réussi quelque chose qui est de au fond
de donner un rendez-vous régulier aux
français en misant sur l'émotion ces
derniers cherchent pas à faire réfléchir
les gens elle chercha à désigner des
bons et des méchants parce que elle sait
que c'est ce qui va susciter
l'engagement ce qui va faire parler
d'elle dans les médias et sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc c'est un très
bon business je pense que ce
documentaire il est celui qui a kout est
le moins cher de l'histoire de première
ligne ce qui ils ont pompé massivement
tout ce qui était disponible ailleurs et
donc je ne vois pas en quoi il apporte
quoi que ce soit au débat public il
aurait sans doute demander enfin dû
demander des conseils à guillaume genton
il aurait eu un documentaire jean daniel
vous avez déjà vu par le passé pour plus
facilement
[Applaudissements]
je suis plutôt d'accord avec gilles
c'est assez rare mais je suis désolé je
suis en temps j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait chose que c'est mc donald's on ne
peut pas dénoncer l'illégalité je suis
désolé un petit entrepreneur qui fait
une faute non c'est ben oui c'est
peut-être jeunes gens c'est le problème
c'est le changement mais daniel il on
s'assure reportage il aurait pu être
fait il ya 15 ans ou 20 ans d'abord
c'est pas un reportage parce que c'est
une fausse investigations oui d'abord on
doit avoir les deux côtés on va voir les
deux côtés il faut savoir qu'il ya des
gens qui sont très heureux de travailler
chez mcdonald's aussi la juge ronald
encore 0
toujours dans des camions il ya toujours
autant d'étudiants qui ont envie de
dire que si tu montres des portes de
chiottes fermé en hiver le personnel ne
peut pas y aller ça dépend de quel angle
on met ce derby ce qu'ils veulent c'est
que les gens passent et repassent quand
les gens sont en train de manger pour
des questions d'hygiène mais à un moment
donné c'est une attaque gratuite je veux
dire elle démarre le reportage en disant
qu'elle même n'aime pas mcdonald's 1
donc si tu me vends mais c'est pas
crédible de frictional dénoncé
mcdonald's et est ce que vous pensez
franchement que ça va toucher mcdonald's
mais n'ont jamais vu un truc et c'est un
beau challenge je
venais au téléphone ir jurandes allemand
sans ben ali étant soir il va plaire
était avec les frites végétaline à
effriter l egypte n les jumelles la
période il m'a dit franchement je m'en
car le cul
non mais quand même il faut il faut
connaître ses services munich non mais
ces deux services ont plu aux missions
de service public le fonds marée il faut
un peu d'honnêteté intellectuelle
après tout on était là quand même
dénoncé en 2017 la paix et dans les
églises sur les prénoms sont donc c'est
pas une émission inutile a bien sûr
contre le reportage d'hier était
totalement inutile mais font du bon
boulot et méchant oui mais pierre non
parce qu'il y en aurait pas d'arrêt des
missions déjà adversaires pas mcdonald's
jamais employé j'ai empêché mes enfants
et chez mcdonald's je veux dire elise
lucet et quand même une excellente
journalisme c'est là en l'occurrence
elle s'est mis les pieds dans le tapis
dès le démarrage en commun je suis
d'accord mais quand vous dites enfoncer
des fortunes vous êtes sûr on est sûr
informés on est beaucoup plus avant mais
que la moyenne ça fait
franchement
intéressant par contre la voix du nord
gagne plus foncée d'euros par mois comme
élise lucet on n'a pas les mêmes
préoccupations que ceux qui balancent
c'est à dire que on peut partir en
vacances avec ses enfants quand la
majorité déjà partis en vacances et donc
aller chez disneyland qu'elle critique
ça par exemple c'est utile pour ces
familles est conçu le plaisir à ces
gamins malheureusement comme on n'a pas
les moyens on les amène au mcdo je
n'étais pas super d'accord je pense que
ça n arrive pas véritablement et les us
et à comprendre qu'elle n'est pas dans
son rôle de l'information et mais mais
mais mais elle prend un parti qui a pas
lieu de mai vous demande juste une chose
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec florian
7 comme ceux-ci d'accord c'est un très
bon ami
et vous voulez dire j je trouve que
florian il prend le l'honnêteté d'élise
lucet pour une tare c'est très honnête
de sa part je dire je n'aime pas
mcdonald's je n'emmène pas mes enfants
chez mcdonald's mais voilà un reportage
sur mcdonald's s'est plaint de lorient
c'est formidable ce que vous dites ça
fait des années qu'elle trouve
des mandats mais ce n'est pas l'accord
il est
alors explorer
6 a dit béatrice et du coup florian à
savoir que que mcdonald's est utile aux
familles modestes mais c'est faux luxe
est utile non mais que seules les
familles modestes qui m'a dit c'est le
cépage la vision c'était pas cher c'est
charles v on est d'accord c'est hyper
cher j'y vais dès fois en famille à 3
anglaise 60 euros à 3 excusez moi c'est
de la malbouffe pour 60 euros oui
mais c'était les mots vous me voyez
prendre trois points mais si les mecs
les plantes qui n'ont jusque là pas du
tout ces six
restaurants ont pas avoir à des vacances
qui ne passent pas à la prison tu veux
faire plaisir à thézan mais je suis
d'accord mais tu as prix moyens ont fait
nous mais il est génial partie
abondant mais
voilà malbouffe à 60 euros autant aller
chez un restaurant bon ça reste passé au
restaurant chez le coiffeur bon là dans
un restaurant oui on va pas dans un
coiffeur à moins que vous soyez prêt à
vous rezé
ma mère si pur